do you think string theory is dead if
you were to bet all your money on
um the future of strength I think it's a
a logical error
to think that string theory is either
right or wrong or dead or alive
what it is is a stepping stone
and uh an analogy I like to draw
is Yang Mills Theory
which I mentioned a few minutes ago in
the context of standard model
yangmail's theory was discovered by
Yangon Mills in the 50s
and they thought that the symmetry of
Yang and Mills
Theory
described the relationship between the
proton and the neutron that's why they
invented it
that turned out to be completely wrong
it does however
describe everything else in the standard
model
and it had a kind of inevitability and
you know they had some of the right
pieces but not the other ones sure they
didn't have it quite in the right
context
and it had an inevitability to it and it
eventually sort of found its place
and it's also true of Einstein's theory
of general relativity you know he had
the wrong version of it in 1914 and he
was missing some pieces and you wouldn't
say that that his early version was
right or wrong he'd understood the
equivalence principle it understood
space-time curvature he just didn't have
everything I mean technically you would
have to say it was wrong
and technically you would have to say
Yang and Mills were wrong and I guess in
that sense
I would believe just
odds are
we always keep finding new wrinkles odds
are we're going to find new wrinkles and
strings Theory and technically what we
call String Theory Now isn't quite right
but we're always going to be wrong but
hopefully a little bit less wrong every
time exactly and I I would you know bet
the farm as they say do you have a farm
I you know I say that much more
seriously because not only do I have a
farm but we just renovated it
I renovated better get the far my wife I
spent five years renovating it before I
you were much much looser with that
statement but now I really need
something no no it really means
something and and I would bet the farm
on the um
on the uh guess that 100 years from now
String Theory will be viewed as a
stepping stone towards a greater
understanding of of nature and and it
would I mean another thing that I didn't
mention about strings theory is of
course we knew that it
solved the Infinities problem and then
we later learned that it also solved
Hawking's puzzle about
what's inside of a black hole
and
put in one assumption you get five
things out you somehow you're doing
something right you know probably not
everything but you're you're you know
there's some good signposts and there
have been a lot of good signposts like
that